I can't even explain what I'm feeling I  can't I just don't think we can get  there at the end I appreciate a thing if  you had to really put a pin on it why  why did Jason go home it was just an  unexplainable moment that I felt in my  heart I just say I felt like you had  fallen so hard for Becca and when you  left I'm there weren't a ton of tears  were you just so in shock I was in  complete shock I just couldn't believe  what had happened the result of it now  it's funny and they didn't show it but  the next day I was a mess cuz it all hit  me it all came to fruition the reality  of the situation said it and I was an  absolute mess at that moment I'm in  Thailand I had everything someone could  ask for I have a suite full of all the  food and drink I want anything you could  ask for  people would dream to have that and it  was one of the most empty moments in my  life because I didn't have my friends  and they're my family  and I just lost her  [Music]  [Applause]